the whole of the West has been imbued by
this idea that we have kind of we've
been born into original sin the original
sin of colonialism the original sin of
empire the original sin of slavery as if
we invented it all you know and in a way
that's see one of my main quarrels with
the left is that they are so racist
they say insist on perceiving the world
through the prism of their own cultural
beliefs so this idea of you know being
being the originators of things like
slavery well it's simply not true and
also this idea that everyone in the
world is basically reasonable we are so
reasonable because we are the Acne of
reason and it's like an imposition so
you know we we collectively in the West
don't even try to understand cultures
which are completely different as we
will not have it they're they're
different they have to be the same as us
we have to see them through the prism of
us because we carry everything before us
to me I find that so at the very least
patronizing but I believe it to be
racist fundamentally racist that it's
not that we're that we in the West think
we're so much better than everybody else
we think that nobody else can be any
different from us it's not possible
because we are just you know what we
stand for is self-evidently wonderful
[Music]